Welcome back everyone this will be my new
marvel wonder man video they just announced
that they're doing a new disney plus series based
on the wonder man characters i'll explain all of
his connections to vision scarlet witch all the
stuff that's happened in marvel movies so far
especially marvel phase four is a big west
coast avengers easter egg too like there's a
lot of west coast avengers happening in marvel
phase 4. there's even legit a bunch of deleted
scenes from guardians of the galaxy 2 featuring
nathan filian as wonder man if you're brand new
to the channel be sure to subscribe to get all
the videos i'm also announcing the winners from
my special bespoke post video during this so look
out for that and thanks to my friends raid shadow
legends for asking to sponsor this video raid
shadow legends is one of the biggest mobile games
in the world right now that's totally free to play
that's right it's free they wanted me to tell you
about their brand new giant prison area called
the dune tower it starts out easy but you'll
need some serious specialist champions on your
team to make it to the higher floors the bosses
ignore block debuffs they can drain your turn
meters and strip your party buffs with certain
bosses like the scarab king requiring very special
tactics from your group and buffs to take down
they've got special events every day including
an entirely new event for the summer solstice
it's called the path of light with three different
branches you can choose with a bunch of different
really cool rewards on top of that those brand
new champions and a brand new set of skins for
trunda guilt mullet raid's currently running a
special delena chase event where new and existing
players can get their hands on the amazing delena
all you have to do is log in and play raid for 7
days between now and july 20th once you're in game
players can enter the promo code mydeliana to get
50 xp brews to max your legendary hero deliana
to level 50 as well as a ton of silver the promo
code is going to be available from may 23rd to
july 20th new players can also use the link in
the description and get a free champion tay ralph
200k silver one xp boost one energy rebuild and
one ancient shard as soon as you start the game
all that free stuff you can find in your inbox in
the upper right hand corner for the next 30 days
so be sure to check it out so the big news is
that marvel just announced they're doing a simon
williams wonder man disney plus series proper it's
from the shangshi director daniel cretton which is
another big surprise on top of them just doing a
wonder man series to begin with i never thought
that they would actually do a wonder man series
or a movie he's such a huge deep cut from the
comics and a lot of the storyline that involves
him like a lot of the connections that he has to
the other avengers characters like vision scarlet
witch has already happened in the plot so far but
the whole thing with the nathan filling and wonder
man deleted scenes is that he played a version of
the character in deleted scenes from guardians of
the galaxy vol 2. that's right james gunn was
going to introduce the character in the mcu
saying that simon williams was a movie star in
the mcu using these movie posters from films he
done in the past this deleted scene was meant to
take place in the present day missouri scenes when
they're showing ego's plan coming to fruition
and he uses all the extra celestial energy from
star-lord to activate his seeds all over the
universe and you see things start to go crazy
with the seeds back in present-day missouri near
the dairy queen where he originally planted it
while this was going on there was meant to be
a simon williams film festival happening nearby
james gunn is from this town in real life his
real-life parents actually cameoed in this scene
all the movies that he starred in here the posters
are meant to be big easter eggs for the comics too
the biggest easter egg is that he played iron man
in a tony stark biopic the arkhan movie poster is
more of a conan reference visually but archon
is actually a real marvel character from the
old school avengers comics now he's a very conan
inspired type of character but conan himself is
actually a different marvel character within the
marvel comics canon arkhan also inspired this
series of arnold schwarzeberger who's meant
to be in arnold schwarzenegger easter egg
movies based on the conan series which the
comic book version of simon williams wonder man
also starred in the way they portray wonder
man in the comics is that his normal alt-ego
type of character like when he's just walking
around normally as simon williams is that he's
a hollywood star like he's an actual actor so
the james gunn arkhan movie poster is like an
easter egg within an easter egg within an easter
egg for the wonder man character dead before a
rival is a movie inspired by christopher nolan's
inception hacksand 2 is a sequel to the fictional
remake of the hacksand movie by rob zombie that
appeared in the movie super directed by james
gunn the toxic janitor movie poster obviously a
reference to the toxic avenger directed by james
gunn's mentor and frequent collaborator lloyd
kaufman james gunn worked for lloyd kaufman at
troma films when he first came to hollywood
that was like his first big hollywood job
and lloyd kaufman also cameos in the guardians
of the galaxy films the o rebecca movie poster
i think is just meant to be a parody of similar
romantic comedies from the early and mid-2000s
maybe also an easter egg about the big love
triangle that wonder man had with scarlet
witch and vision during the wandavision series
there were a couple references to wonder man
completely separate from what was happening with
these deleted guardians of the galaxy 2 scenes
it was mostly through the white vision storyline
but also in the opening credits too during the
opening credits when the camera is panning through
all the different rooms and the floors of the
house you see a helmet the helmet is from the grin
reaper in the comics who was wonder man's brother
who attacked the avengers after thinking that they
were responsible for the death of his brother but
the big twist is that part of wonder man's thing
is that he always comes back after he seemingly
dies and this time he just happened to be in a
coma later you see the sword and tyler hayward
have tried to recreate vision resuscitate him
using his body parts from avengers infinity war
in the comics originally the avengers had to do
the same thing they tried to use the brain powders
from wonder man again to create the same effect
that vision got from the soul stone in the mcu
along with the jarvis and the ultron ai
programming originally in the comics when
ultron created vision he stole wonder man's brain
patterns that had been backed up by hank pym when
they were still trying to save wonder man's life
and just use the brain waves to create vision's
personality matrix they kept bringing wonderman
back to life periodically one time king the
conqueror brought him back to life as part of an
evil team he created to fight the avengers called
legion of the unliving after a few more villains
bring him back to life i think he died like six
times in the comics but each time he was brought
back by a different type of villain that tried to
use him to fight the avengers eventually he takes
control of his own mind then joins the avengers
then moves to hollywood becomes this big star
and helps found the west coast avengers so that's
where all the movies that he stars in come from
we keep making jokes about all the west coast
avengers easter eggs in the disney plus series in
the movies during marvel phase four this is like
the next really big one introducing his character
legit he did have a love triangle with scarlet
witch after she'd already been married to vision
they tried to say that wonder man had feelings for
her first because they thought that vision only
loved scarlet witch leading to their marriage
because his brain waves were literally copied from
wonder man's like his love of scarlet witch came
from wonder man's love of scarlet witch very
mellow dramatic a lot of these classic marvel
comics and this gets back to the whole thing with
tyler hayward and sword trying to recreate vision
they tried to do this a couple times in the comics
like vision would be destroyed and the avengers
would try to recreate him when they're trying
to recreate his body scarlet witch goes back to
wonder man to ask to provide his brain waves once
again so they can do the same thing and create the
same personality matrix for vision basically
his powers are kind of like captain america's
powers except he's more powerful like thor or the
hulk so he's way stronger way more durable than
captain america and unlike captain america he has
a couple extra powers on top of that too his real
name is simon williams but he got his powers from
baron zemo who also gave him the wonder band name
after he found out his company had been rendered
near bankrupt by iron man's company stark
industries so thinking that he hated iron man
baron zemo wanted to use him against iron man
all the power that he imbued him with was through
an experiment involving ionic energy so you say
wonder man's powers are all based on ionic energy
speaking of which they actually just confirmed
that baron zemo is coming back again during the
thunderbolts movie that marvel just announced
they'll pay off those val madame hydra cameo
scenes during falcon and winter soldier the
black widow movie we'll also probably see her in
the she-hulk series recruiting abomination next
i just did a whole video on the thunderbolts
movie who's going to be on that team so i'll
link it at the end of this i'm doing all the miss
marvel episodes right now they get into a lot of
the captain marvel mythology wonder man is also
supposed to be stronger than captain marvel most
of the time when she's not gone full binary he's
been able to fight the hulk to a stalemate in his
normal hulk form he can soak blasts of the power
cosmic from the silver surfer he's effectively
immortal like he can come back to life each time
he dies and when he comes back in the comics each
time he seems like he becomes more powerful he can
also fly and he can give off his ionic energy from
his eyes in the form of beams and from his hands
but now they're introducing him thor's gonna have
to wear that trucker hat with strongest avenger on
it just to boost his ego just a little bit longer
he also shows up a lot in the x-men comics too he
gets involved a lot with rogue so maybe they'll
cross them over with a lot of what's going on in
the avengers movies when they start doing x-men
stuff too also he's kind of like the hollywood
avenger like the she-hulk series for instance
takes place in los angeles he's probably going to
be another los angeles-based avengers character
and remember initially when he debuted in the
comics he debuted as a villain but it was one
of those situations where the villains were trying
to twist his mind against the avengers and mislead
him so fundamentally he is a good character like i
said what will probably happen with his character
in the mcu is that they'll balance his
powers a little so that he's not too op
like he probably won't do everything that he
does in the comics but just like they changed
a lot of miss marvel's origin story even though
there are easter eggs for the comic book version
of her origin story it'll probably be the same
situation with wonder man a lot of the changes
they make are meant to fit them better with
what they've already done in the mcu so far
they haven't announced an actor yet it probably
won't be nathan fillion though the james gunn
guardians of the galaxy 2 scenes will probably
just stay deleted scenes technically those aren't
meant to be canon so like they can change stuff if
they have easter eggs for related things everyone
post all your theories in the comments below or if
you have any questions about what's going on with
wonder man just in general how he's going to fit
into the mcu just write it below in the comments
congratulations driven xavier ramirez in
ragin at games you guys are the winners of
those special bespoke post boxes please email me
on the about page of my channel or on my website
emergencyawesome.com so i can get your contact
info everyone click here for my brand new loki
season 2 first look video and everyone click here
for that marvel thunderbolts announcement video
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!